why is it theatrically released so
important to you it's a lot of work it
is a lot of work in my pressure movies
are meant to be seen in a movie dinner I
feel um and even though we're giving
away iphone versions as part of the
Kickstarter campaign it just feels like
you know there's you can't really
compare to and we're guilty of it too
with our you know TV to sitting at home
and watching movies but there's
something about seeing a movie in a
theater and and you know we played at
all these festivals and people come up
to us afterward and they say really nice
things and they say I wish Hollywood
made movies like this this movie could
be in a theater and um you know and so
with a wall maybe the right and so we
thought we'd just try not people show
them the trailer in our campaign video
and see what they thought also with we
do have a digital dish distributor who's
distributing the film you get better
placement on iTunes if you've done a
theatrical so if they can say it's
playing in this theater this year in
this theater then your trailer gets
moved up to a better position so the
more eyeballs are on it so that can
possibly you know sell more because you
know it's like you're strolling through
you know all the choices I'm not going
to buy a movie on iTunes that I've never
heard of so we have to figure out how to
make other people by our movie that
they've never heard of we don't have a
big publicity campaign and so
Kickstarter's it's also works as our
publicity campaign to try to get people
who haven't heard of it before to see it
so even if we don't make our goal which
I hope is not the case will still be
getting the word out to a bunch of
people already who hadn't heard of the
film before and are now aware of it and
how did you determine that 25,000 is the
number math okay one of the things we
learned from our person at hand is that
you have to be very careful with
shipping prices
then that really that really bit us last
night so we just we broke it down in
terms of we have a DVD distributor and
in order to fulfill the dvds like we you
know yet we have to buy from wholesale
from them so we have the dvds we forgot
all about this much will buy from them
to fulfill how much your envelopes how
much sure I mean bubble mailer a lot of
that is actually just fulfilling
incentives a lot of the $25,000 is
fulfilling the incentives that we've set
and then on top of that is the theater
rentals and then some of the
distribution costs that are for the the
digital distribution like making the the
digi beta tapes that go to the VOD
company and all that stuff a lot of
costs associated with actually selling
your movie you don't even realize he's
all greatly of a VOD distributor amazing
if I selling you mean you have someone
who's going to be saved a movie for you
yes we don't have any money yeah so
there's lots of costs that you incur by
having good things happen so so when
life is good it's expensive yes yes well
do you think that filmmakers should self
distribute their own work what are your
thoughts on I think they should have a
plan to do it we definitely consider
doing it we had a very bumpy road with
with getting our distribution because we
had a fail to people liked when they saw
it but we didn't have buzz coming off of
like a Sundance or you know like beasts
of the southern while I've got a
theatrical release because it was a
Sundance movie that you know I don't
name anything else i was at Sundance
this year but I know about that one um
so without that kind of buzz and without
like big huge names you know the
business people don't care whether it's
a good movie or not they would rather
have a bad movie that has Antonio
Banderas and Eddie Murphy as buddy cops
or whatever are we were going to write
that now that sounds great let's do that
and i would probably
we pay our rent for a while um you guys
that mean sure okay uh so I don't
remember my point was I was talking
about distribution Oh should feel make
herself distribute yeah so you have to
thank you can see how they did it and
then maybe do that next time oh um like
you can go through distribute calm where
you play like a flat fee and then it
helps this an aggregator to get you on
iTunes and Amazon and Hulu and Netflix
and all that stuff but that just helps
you get on there it doesn't help with
marketing or whatever so it but you
don't have to pay a sales agent or you
don't have to pay a distributor or
percentage so you get to keep her thing
comes in so it's possible um do things
changing right now so much and there's
so many cool companies like distribute
disturber or like TOCOM that are that
are popping up and I wish someone would
hurry up and become the thing to do so
that it would be much easier what
because you can self distribute and
definitely if you if you can't get
anyone to help you then you definitely
should more like hybrid distribution
where you you know you're doing some
things yourself and the distributors
doing some things with just more what
we're doing because we're also sort of
self distributing on our on our website
we're gonna be selling the DVD and
Digital done we'll probably have them in
the trunks of our car for the next ten
years or so to if anyone sees us around
right um but we chose to go that way so
just doing it all ourselves just because
we want to make another movie too I
don't want to be your water yeah that's
not something I'm personally interested
in we may have to be because that's how
the industry is is turning but I would
like someone else to do that for us so
we can make another movie the industry
seems to be moving towards the model of
the music industry where it's you know
our marketing directly to their fans and
creating content you know smaller niche
content so like no one's making the big
you know money that they used to make
but you know there's something
merchandise and stuff and people are
supporting them that way and we actually
use topspin which is this great company
that a lot of musicians use to sell
their stuff Amanda Palmer pit the pixies
dead can dance who else uses it Kevin
Samantha I think I Patty's Day and we
love them we sell our book through them
and we will sell the movie through there
so there's who knows what's going to
happen it's really a matter of getting
the word out you know if you're the
small filmmaker and you have your film
you're going to self distribute them
sell on your website you're going to go
through disturb well then how do you get
beyond your friends and family and a
like Kickstarter IndieGoGo is that this
is step you know at the beginning the
process of getting out there to a wider
audience and then you know after that
you can branch out but we haven't
figured out how to build that that
audience yet that's what amazing stuff
that where we ck is doing with his
selling things directly to audiences he
couldn't do that if he wasn't already
Louie CK well he could but he wouldn't
be making a million dollars for ed burns
radio they reach a certain level of Fame
and then they're able to sort of the
people are branching off and doing that
the key is well how do people like us or
like you or think you know people
watching how do they if they don't have
the the name
and to export out there how do they make
that shift and which we're trying to
figure that out ourselves you think if I
took my top off right now that will help
yes
you